before we get started i feel the need to
remind you that the news arm of the bbc
ran a quote-unquote article on trans
women containing misleading information
and provable falsehoods as well as
platforming a woman who then went on to
make a literal call for the genocide of
trans women and while that individual's
comments have been stricken from the
article the bbc has yet to address the
fact that they platformed her and has
not disavowed or condemned her
statements
you can find links in a pinned comment
below for relevant videos if you do not
know what i'm talking about that being
said
on with the show
what the flux just happened
[Music]
[Music]
doctor who flux
finale episode six
the vanquishers
well
i'll start with about the most
backhanded compliment i can hand the
thing which is it did not do
any of the massively terrifyingly stupid
things that i saw theorized by people
none of which i would have put past
chibnall the big one being the reveal
that belle and vinder's kid was going to
actually turn out to be the doctor
just you know tiny whiny
timeless child shenanigans and a bunch
of other theories like along those kinds
of lines of bonkers none of that
happened
so there's only so much credit i'm gonna
give a thing for not being as
bad
as i was kind of afraid it would be
but to be fair i was dreading a lot
worse
than we got as far as that goes
there was actually
one scene
that was genuinely great
possibly one of the best performances
i've seen jodie whittaker give and the
part it characterized the doctor it
managed to deliver exposition but in a
way that was energizing and felt really
interesting
and i'll talk about it later because i i
feel like i'm going to
want to pick me up
part way through this so
hold on to that and remember i am going
to say something nice
so hold on to that
keep that in mind
as i just kind of throw out my hands and
go
i
i don't
i don't know why
this
like at all but here's here's one of the
things that i like i tried doing a
little
looking into this but i didn't have any
luck um
so if somebody can actually cite sources
on this i'd appreciate it i've had more
than a few people mention in the
comments that this was originally
supposed to be ten episodes um and they
cut it down to six now the problem is i
can't source that or at least not in
terms of the episode cut came after the
writing had in some way started or had
been
begun to get worked on
because while yes this is a shorter
series than the previous one was so
obviously they did cut down episodes i
have not found anything that says that
chibnall was working initially with the
understanding that he had more episodes
than he ended up with
i can't source that that's the case
somebody has a source i'd appreciate it
because
it would answer a whole lot of questions
in terms of how this ended up the way it
did because
so much about this the finale
especially more than anything but
honestly the whole thing
really except for episode two
maybe a little bit episode four but
pretty much all of it
has the distinct feel
of something that thought it was gonna
have more time to tell this story and
has to cram everything because like
well let me put it another way
i'm trying to figure out
if i need to be annoyed at chibnall
for
you know being stuck in a position of
thinking he had more episodes
uh getting told he had fewer and then
failing to correctly adjust the story
instead trying to cram the entire thing
in
to just the sixth episode i would
consider this the gotham season five
problem uh because that's a
that that is a season that they we know
they went in thinking they were
initially gonna have more and then it's
very clear you watched that season you
didn't restructure once you realized
this was going to be your final season
you took every idea that you wanted to
do eventually and crammed it all into
one
and this has that same feel so either
he was told after starting to work on
this that he was gonna have fewer
episodes and then he just failed to make
the removals he did because honestly
even though one of these is my is the
episode i think is the best in this and
one of them is one that everybody else
on the planet liked but honestly if
you're trying to tell a continuous story
this overlapping and complicated
you ditch or streamline
war for the santarans and village of the
angels village of the angels actually
you could cut almost completely and war
for the centaurus maybe you couldn't cut
completely but you could streamline that
down a lot
and have more breathing room for
everything else because everything else
needs it it feels
so cramped and so crowded but either i
need to criticize gymnal for that or i
need to criticize him for thinking that
he could pull off this many stories this
many new characters this many big
implications all converging at the same
time in six episodes
it's it doesn't work either way
and it's his fault either way
i'm just trying to figure out am i
blaming him for failing to adjust his
plans or for his plans just not being
good
from the get-go
which maybe even at 10 episodes might
have been the case but that's a
hypothetical it's not even worth dealing
with so i like
okay so right right now so far i'm kind
of talking for from a presumption of
this didn't work and i should explain
why i think it didn't work because
otherwise i'm just talking from a
presumption of authority which
i don't have i'm not i'm not an
authority on authority on anything other
than my own opinion which is what i'm
here to talk about so if you don't like
what i'm saying
i don't know what to tell you
so
the
sheer volume of things
trying to be wrapped up
here
left me wondering
why did you even introduce
some of these
so
like
okay
so the ravagers
swarm and azure
the performances aren't bad swarm
especially is actually kind of kind of
interesting
but we get so little time and
understanding
who these people are
what their investment is exactly why it
is they're trying to pull off what they
are i never fully wrap my head around
that and honestly i'm gonna come back to
what i said way back
in the first or second episode
why isn't this an existing character
because rather than taking the time to
get us to know these villains and you're
forcing them to share screen time with a
ton of other stuff if you'd pulled an
existing villain
even a classic arrow one that hadn't
been introduced into modern era anymore
i mean like how easily would omega have
slotted into this
ultimately we find out that the flux is
anti-matter
that's
omega's whole deal
is freaking anti-matter
whatever missed opportunity but my point
being
these feel like
underserved villains
because there isn't the room to flesh
them out for me to get a good
appreciation from them other than just
the sheer presence of the performance
which isn't nothing but it's not enough
not when you're hinging so much of the
plot on this there's the grand dragon
who honestly i cannot figure out the
point of
truly
feels like the kind of thing that you
cut
from this story when you've only got six
episodes and so much stuff crapped in
why what is he what is he what is the
point of him
what where's the like
he's just here he's just an opportunist
who's here so far as i can tell
like and that's sort of what i mean
where i would absolutely believe that
this was originally intended to be ten
episodes because if this was ten
episodes you'd have the space to have an
opportunistic wild card villain adding
extra complication but when you've only
got six
you cut that guy
but
he's just there
he's just there i don't know why
i don't know why
any writer would think he was worth
sinking time into that could have been
put into characterizing any number of
other things going on and okay
how cavalier this entire series
and kind of the doctor too by extension
is about the
implied
body count
that really
doesn't sit right with me now i have to
say implied body count because we don't
see that many die we see jericho die
still probably uh the standout mvp of
this series not gonna lie he he had a
good exit it was a good performance i
like to that character see i can say
nice things sometimes now and then not
many i know
but
okay
so we had
a couple of confirmed deaths but
we have
talked about the death of the entire
lupari species aside from calvinista and
the doctor
says about that
sorry about the rest of your species
okay
we have
the presumed death of every person other
than die who was inside passenger which
begs the question what was the freaking
point of any of that and why is she in
there
because azure and swarm like went out of
their way to find her unless i'm
completely misremembering way back in
the first episode why why did they care
about her why did they get her why did
they single her out why is she the only
one in there where did everybody else go
why were they being collected why
any of it
so we have the implication
of the deaths of however many people
could be kept in passenger they said at
one point i forget what it was now
so we have that as an implied body count
and
i asked this on twitter
and maybe like at some point somebody
will give me an answer
but like at the time that i i checked
back on it nobody had a firm answer on
this
how much of the universe got destroyed
by the flux before they stopped it
because the only thing that they went
out of their way to confirm was safe was
earth
so
how
many
planets
solar systems
galaxies
are gone
and it feels like there is no proper
acknowledgement of that
you know as much as i did
and will still complain about things
like
the uh end of series three
where there is this year where a ton of
people are wiped out on the planet and
all this stuff and then at the end of uh
last of the time lords the year just
gets rolled back
and so it never happened as much as i
hate that because it removes the stakes
of the situation like why go that big if
you're not going to stick with the
consequences this is somehow even worse
because at least rolling it back and
undoing it the way that did or the way
the big bang which i also don't like did
at least those things by taking the time
to roll those back acknowledge that that
was a really bad thing that shouldn't be
allowed to happen
but here
it doesn't even feel acknowledged that
it happened
so one of two things is going on
either it does not properly establish
exactly how dangerous this thing is how
much damage it did or didn't do what i'm
overestimating which is possible or i'm
right and whole chunks of the universe
are gone and there's like no
acknowledgement of that
at the end of this we're just like let's
get ready for another adventure what
and also
what was the point of the thing with the
daleks and the cybermen
like it's not a completely uninteresting
notion for the santorans to do
for them to say hey you're trying to
flee the flux let's
let you know get all here and we'll
protect you and then we'll we'll be at a
negotiated piece and then wipe them out
like for a minute i did think why would
either the dogs or the sartorians bring
their entire fleets there that's not how
negotiation works but then i but then i
got my oh right there they're trying to
avoid the flux so this is a desperation
move
maybe they might
so it's not that it was bad
strategically for the centaurons it
wasn't but what was the point
what was the point in sinking time into
that especially because at the very end
of this thing after the credits will you
give us a preview of what's happening
for the new year's day special you show
us daleks so clearly it didn't wipe
every one of them out and maybe they'll
even address that when we get there
maybe they will but it doesn't change
the fact that this completely undercuts
this thing that you added here so now i
really find myself wondering why was
that here
why
i haven't asked that question this much
about any singular episode since hell
bent
honestly
why any of it
why is kate here
lots of people in the comments on the
last episode were like you didn't even
mention kate stewart's being back what
the heck was there to say other than
just to state the fact that she was back
her presence contributes
nothing she doesn't even add a flavor or
bring her chemistry to the mix because
she's such a small part of this because
it's so
over
stuffed
nobody has time to contribute anything
as an actor as a character as a
chemistry or as a dynamic because the
plot is so stuffed to the gills this
thing is just dashing front to back and
doing nothing other than trying to tie
up all its threads and doing it very
messily and very poorly but that is
literally all it has time for so these
additional characters being put in
characters that i even like like kate
have no purpose and are just there she
might as well have been furniture
and then there's the thing with the with
the watch which
chimney
do me a favor
before the last of the specials
that you are responsible for
get finalized to get filmed
get a dictionary
and look up the word
payoff
understand what
payoff is
because you do so much setup
so much setup
and so
little payoff and do not
say to me well the story's gonna be
continued in the specials because i have
been listening to it'll get dealt with
later it'll go down with later it'll get
dealt with later ever since the freaking
timeless child happened
no you don't get to kick the can
that far down the road you have to stop
and actually deal with it and have
payoff
for
things you
set up
the watch
is now just the thing that she has that
presumably she'll open in the later
specials assuming chimney remembers that
it's there
serve no point here didn't function the
way these things have ever functioned
before and i'm not getting on that as a
continuity because i'm not a continuity
hound but like what sense does it make
that previously the whole thing was you
open it and the time lord essence just
goes into whatever time load it was
taken from and they just are again
they're whole and they remember and now
it's it takes you to this weird twisted
house with all your lives uh
you know
being represented by these
twisted formations of a house and
the ravagers can also be there for some
reason even though theoretically this is
all going on in your head it is not a
physical space for them to occupy
and like uh uh
and what in the hell
happened at the end
where like they
they freed briefly
time they okay so they just say the word
time a whole lot in this franchise this
series like the planet is called time
we're here to unleash time time is chaos
time is dangerous time is the the
antithesis of space or whatever the heck
it was and then we have these things
like it's time and like it looks like
swarm and then it kills them and then it
looks like the doctor and is all ominous
which is very reminiscent of the he will
knock four times stuff from the end of
tenants run i didn't like it then i
don't like it now
and
what is going on
and look here's the thing
in this particular case i'm not asking
it as if there is no answer i'm sure
there's an answer i am sure that if i
were to re-watch it
two three more times and like pay super
careful attention i could get what was
going on and piece it together my point
though is i shouldn't have to do that
i'm not complaining because answers
don't exist
i'm complaining because they're
presented
badly
and that's for the stuff we do get
answers for because other stuff as i
said just gets
kicked down the road again
okay so i i i promised you i was gonna
say something nice
you know as much as i complain about the
grand serpent he is a pointless
character but you know what
the interrogation scene where he tries
to interrogate the doctor
and she is just spouting facts about him
right back at him
that was great
that was one of the best scenes that
i've seen jody whitaker get to play
because it is expositional it is
explanatory but to compare it to like
well honestly most of her dialogue in a
lot of the stuff especially written by
chipnol where she just says stuff is
like i said ah and like it's a bit like
when tennant would ravel would um just
rapid fire technobabble and though oh
nice now that whole bit
here she is delivering exposition about
how he works and a little bit about who
he is
doesn't really matter all that much of
the plot but within the scene
she's needling him with this information
so it doesn't feel like an exposition
dump she's throwing in his face like ooh
dictator you've got that kind of
entitlement and there's a lot more
expression and characterization in the
way she says it the way she says certain
words the way she needles him and picks
at him and she's not just she's not just
being self-righteous she is getting
a reaction out of him and i really
enjoyed watching that
genuinely
not sure there was too much else that i
liked very much but i did genuinely like
that you know
i feel like i kind of want to end on
that note actually
i could go through
all this
stuff
and find other things that i like i feel
like didn't get tied up or whatever but
it doesn't feel worth it
like this this thi this thing has nodded
my brain
yeah
and i i don't i don't feel like
unraveling that right now
because i don't feel like i'd
get anything satisfying to me
if i tried to do that
i didn't find the viewing experience
particularly enjoyable i don't think
it's going to improve enough
on trying to
untangle all this
to have it be worth the effort
maybe
i'll think slightly better of it at a
later time when i've had more time to
think on it
but right now
i just want to go to bed
the finale of doctor who flux
i am gonna have to think about this
thing because i need to um
i need to i need to
do an overview of the whole thing that's
what i'm going to be doing for saturday
to really try and
put this thing into a into a
i don't know some kind of context but
for right now i'm just done
this entire production was made possible
by the support of my patrons over on
patreon if you are able to support me
it would be greatly appreciated don't
sweat it too much though
you
can give me your thoughts whatever they
are agree or disagree drop them down in
the comments and let's talk about it
the usual stuff that helped me fight off
the algorithm which is not being very
nice to me right now outside of doctor
who which means now that this series is
over it's probably going to start
kicking my ass again um
so
like share subscribe all help me out
quite a bit
but don't worry too much about it
at the end of the day
you are the council
i am just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey if you're sticking around through
the credits might as well hear some
names read out my patreon helps support
this and in particular i want to thank
raven mcbain bookworm mj tracy scrabbit
vincent paul bartolucci kailyn schwartz
edelman robin moore ross schultz shayla
gourlay want to hear me mispronounce
your name check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]